oggi ragazzi un video un po strano
perché hanno fatto una roba che ha
dell'incredibile
c'è veramente questo sito che fa in
disegno o tipo questo è lui che lo telo
colorato come se fosse reale ceti creato
la foto c'è addirittura non sono un
ragazzo sia possibile prova funzionato
tipo noi facciamo un vero disegno
l'altro giorno sono in reale quindi
facciamo creiamo un viso che questo sito
può riconoscere e trasformarlo in reale
allora questa dice fermi tutti mi sto
impegnando per fare sta roba non mi sono
mai impegnato per fare un disegno in
vita mia che qualche quanto edifici di
come sarà la gente a disegnare non mi
mandate messaggi mi devo concentrare va
bene il secondo occhio e bellissimo
scusa omero provato a farti al meglio
possibile
cioè io vi giuro che rispetto rispetto
ai soliti disegni che faccio io sta roba
è il capolavoro d'arte moderna voi che
mi conoscete che sapete come disegno
stato grasso cioè sta roba non è male
siete pronti raga pronti per distruggere
la vostra infanzia 321 notte a tutti ma
che malattia e non lo stop al 2
ciambelle al posto degli occhi
trattandosi di homer simpson anche un
senso due tette al posto degli occhi
sembra che i due tette 72 ciambelle 1
l'effetto della bomba atomica di
cernobyl suo homer simpson sembra una
patata placati lorenzo lotto di temi
sono sempre a claudio bisio
porca vacca uguale spetta ora rega
family soffrendo far claudio bisio
claudio claudio 6 per essere
protagonista di un avido si contendo e
quadri deve impegnare un sarà
fortunatamente i capelli di esco easy
con claudio c'è proprio un problema in
meno
no io non riuscire a fare un cerchio il
mio problema fermi fermi che ci riprova
non riesco a fare la testa di claudio
bisio che problemi a questa già con un
po più tonda un po più paramiliare
bravo claudio peri tutti equa claudio è
deve essere onorato di questo disegno
poi glielo chiediamo se li faccio il
terzo occhio la ghetta in singh raga
raga ole ole bellissimo grazie claudio
che ci hai prestato da te immagine
adesso vediamo il sito che cosa ne pensa
il colore della maglietta l'azzeccato
poi il resto no però dopo che ti ha
messo i capelli che problema a questo
sito perché ha perso i capelli a che
oggi ban alla non avevo disegnato i
capelli
ragazzi questo e questo è questa la mia
è la mia più grande soddisfazione
comunque essere in grado di far
trasparire la mia arte ho bisogno di
sapere cosa ne pensa la gente voglio
saperlo ragazzi adesso abbiamo scherzato
passiamo a immagini serie ok che tra
l'altro tra tutti forse quello che mi è
venuto meglio pensate che che che merda
disegno fatto prima era ciò di cui avevo
bisogno meraviglioso stefano che
guarderei questo video si è pronto
perché è un mondo soprattutto perché gli
ho fatto le sopracciglia normalissime e
gli è venuto un mono sopracciglio qual è
il problema che cos'è che jackie
problemi a questo gioco perché ha la
bocca nera restano l'infanzia nnsc
libert step lido pro 10 birre stecchini
dopo che un camion gli è passato sopra
eric opa prima cosa che si individua
anche imbeccato alla foto che ho tra
copiato versione baguette brucia next
one ragazzi insalate che avrei messo
solo stefano vi sbagliate tutti
anche daniel hofer mills per tendola
spende solo fare un alieno che lo faccio
dopo suri ormai venuto troppo bene da
alieno che la madonna mi chiama vento
benissimo ecco gli alieni mi vengono
bene che non è una cagata a farli prova
ben project lo voglio verde fantastic lo
abbiamo scherzato adesso serie occupo
ottima o o perfetto le proporzioni sono
giuste salvo è venuto bene raga non so
perché è venuto è uguale cazzola che sto
migliorando tuba basta non faccio più
per cosa fare richard htpc saraga
processi storia ma ora sembra non voglio
sapere cosa sembra ok ragazzo ria
visualizzato
ho bisogno di una sua risposta subito o
cos'è io a 70 mido ha dato alcuna
malattia ha fatto brutta questa malattia
che urla lesbica l'infermiera ne mancano
due ragalo sapete sasha renderà
giustizia la tua persona a te lo
prometto che ha un sacco di stile
secondo me non è niente male vai places
i capelli sono identici i capelli sono
fottutamente identici resta la merda una
papera con la paralisi facciale beh più
o meno pedro e per ultimo ma non per
importanza papa vegas
eccolo con la pa paci 6 papa guarda
questo video che bello guarda come ti
faccio bene giusto e c6 papa e stai
guardando questo video tipo e un sacco
bene
giudicarmi dopo questa roba
vai processo cazzo uguale ma ora ga
finito sa i vecchietti antipatici nei
cartoni uguale
da notare la precisione ne parli pure la
fossetta eh beh a me sembra un incubo
tutto ciò zia hai ragione dillo che
sarei di strangio è mascalzone novi
stava andando queste cose perché ho
delle mancanze forti nella mia vita
ultimo ragazzi ma non per importanza
signori tra totti forse quella che mi è
venuto meglio ci siete regala 3 2 1 la
mia vita sta per finire qui ma ci
metterei la firma per essere così la
mattina comunque raga io vorrei dirvi
che tra tutti i lavori di oggi c'è della
qualità e se invece della qualità
io la metterei come foto di qualsiasi
cosa anche della carta d'identità la
fotogrammi acate dita e molto peggiori
magari conseguenze se stesso con dei
problemi allora se non vi ho dei
problemi anche senza di segnarvi così
tanto lo sappiamo tutti che si
registrano un video lo caricare sul
canale non ti sfugge proprio nulla
max a ok perspicace chi sei perché
questa albano al bano chiudiamo come al
bano eccolo qua il mio uomo
dai che sto cappello western proprio che
risale ai tuoi tempi
so che la figlia di al bano e mia fan
perché mi ha chiesto una foto l'altro
giorno è che tesoro se guardi questo
video qua fallo vedere al papa che
sicuramente sarà contento di apprezzare
le mie doti artistiche albano se guardi
questo video che apprezzo un sack corsa
i però se vai in giro per strada ci sono
artisti migliori me però io mi sto
impegnando
qui almeno bravo per l'impegno lo
gradirei grazie eccolo qua grande albano
l'ho fatto molto meno sorridente di
quello che dovrebbe essere però la
signora bana non si spaventi seguiti se
stavano questo video non si spaventi il
risultato finale perché così per tutti
ci siete raga
ecco
quindi ragazzi spero che il video di
oggi vi sia piaciuto subito messo un
sacco di impegno grazie al bano che hai
guardato giusto video lascia mi piace
anche tu a bra tra boss non ha capito
lui ha capito cosa senza senso come non
mi piace anche vari social che come
descrizione essere si discute ci
mettiamo al prossimo vita dei ragazzi
[Musica]